All right.
What's your background, dude?
What's up, Sam? How are you? I'm good,
Sebastian. What do you believe? What's
your Christian background? Oh, I'm
Catholic. Okay, good. Talk to me. Yeah,
I have only one question about Matthew
Yeah, I have a question about Matthew
14:51
and what is the meaning about the young
Matthew naked
14:51 Okay.
14:51. That's interesting. Okay, what
about it? You want to just sit by here?
Let me read your heart, Donald.
Oh, good question.
Yes, uh I I
My question is what is the meaning about
the young man fleeing naked and what is
the what
>> I didn't know what you were talking
about. There is no Matthew 14:51. That's
why you threw me off. It's Mark 14:51,
sorry.
>> Ah, yes. Yes, sorry. Sorry.
>> why, guys, I got a brain freeze? They go
Matthew 14:51.
Matthew ends in 14:33. See, this is what
you did to me. I'm like, what? Matthew
14:51
Matthew ends in verse 33.
Yeah. And why are you smashing your uh
your computer? See, guys, why I got a
brain freeze? I'm like, wait, wait,
wait. Let's see if I Did you find a new
manuscript?
Wait. Was it outside? The one you were
digging?
Did you find a new It's Mark 14:51,
buddy.
Astaghfirullah. Astaghfirullah.
Why are you smashing your keyboard,
dude?
Yeah, no, I'm just typing something
here. I'm just Because you want to see
if I'm right, right? No, I'm I'm seeing
if I'm wrong.
Yes.
>> 14:33. Matthew ends in verse 33. That's
why you threw me off. What? Matthew
14:51.
>> Yeah.
Mark 14:51. What about it?
No, I'm asking about the the young man
that is seen fleeing naked in the
Gospels.
So, when you talked about a young boy
naked, you kind of scared me. Yeah, what
about him?
Yeah, because in the Gospels, uh it is
said that when Jesus was going to be
arrested
>> I don't get what you're asking me.
I think it would be more like what would
compel the Holy Spirit to to inspire the
authors of the Gospel
>> Because that would tell you that this
must be an eyewitness account. It's
giving you details that an eyewitness
would recount because this was something
that was etched in his memory, so you
can then be assured that you're getting
eyewitness testimony because
eyewitnesses will mention will remember
details that to someone else may not be
significant who wasn't there.
Mhm. Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> You got it, pal?
Yeah. Yeah, that that that makes sense.
That makes sense, actually.
>> it says now in Mark 14:51, what does it
say?
No, it
does says that a young man was seen
fleeing naked.
What? And he threw off his garment.
Now, that would be something that an
eyewitness would remember cuz it would
be etched in his mind, right? Yes.
That's why it's written. It's trying to
tell you
that you see this took this stood out
to me
because
Mhm.
the situation was so desperate that
everyone tried to flee for their life
that this guy didn't even care
that he would end up running naked
right?
Because to him, saving his life was more
important
right? Than
being arrested. Even if it meant that
he'd have to run naked.
That's something that would
make an impact an eyewitness who was
there to have seen it. And the tradition
tells us that this is Mark writing down
the Gospel of Peter. So, that means as
Peter is narrating the very events that
he saw, there would be certain events
and moments that would have left an
impact such as, man, it was so dire that
night that there was even a young boy
that fled to escape the soldiers
to the point that
he fled naked to get away from them.
See, this is eyewitness
anecdotal testimony. Now, interestingly,
there's another tradition that says that
young boy was John Mark, the very writer
of the Gospel.
Mhm.
You with me there?
Yes. Yes. Yes. I'm with you there.
>> So, it it and
a tradition, guys, you can confirm this.
There's actually a tradition says the
young boy was John Mark.
So, now if it is John Mark, that makes
more sense because then John Mark is
writing the Gospel of Mark and he's
mentioning
that
this is what happened to him out of fear
and desperation, they grabbed him by his
cloak, but he ran naked to escape their
clutches.
Now, I don't know if John Mark wrote it
but again, I wouldn't be surprised.
So, there you go.
Did that help you?
Yes. Yes. Yeah, it actually does, Sam.
It actually does. It was only that. It
was only
>> I can call heaven if you want to ask for
specific details. [snorts and laughter]
I can ask if Mark is available or Peter.
Why Why are you laughing at me, bro?
Uh because I wish we could do that, you
know, have a straight line to heaven and
ask.
They told me don't abuse my privilege.
Only call when necessary. So, if you got
your answer, save me the trouble cuz
they're saying the more you call, we're
going to have to disconnect your line.
Yeah. Yeah, no. No worries. No worries.
Really really
desperate time. So, if I don't need to
call cuz every time I call, I take a
chance cuz sometimes the question class
get angry.
All right?
Yes. Yes. I will do it myself.
So, you're okay, though?
Yes. Yes. Yes. I got to answer my
question.
>> by pretending there are verses in
Matthew 14 that don't exist? No, Sam. I
will not.
Sam, the Can you hear me? Brother, to
read it for you, I can ask Michael. Can
I Can I read it? There you go. It's for
you.
Do you want Gabriel to read it for you?
I can ask you, Michael.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I I will read it.
Okay. Then, hold on.
I haven't called heaven for a while.
Can I have Gabriel read it for him? Call
heaven.
I want to ask Gabriel to read it for
you. Is that okay?
Yeah, I I will do it myself. No. No. No.
Wait. Wait. Wait, brother. Hold on. And
I want to do it with glasses, I do.
>> Why are you laughing? Okay. Oh my
goodness. Cuz it is
uh Sabbath and we're supposed to be
observing Sabbath, right?
Yes. They tell me they say we're
supposed to be observing Sabbath. So,
let me let me call Gabriel. I have a
direct line to Gabriel. You ready?
Hey, man. You should hear this song.
[music] It's Stairway to Heaven. You get
it? Stairway to Heaven. And she's buying
stairway.
Hello.
Shabbat shalom. Baruch Hashem. Hey, can
I sing a song?
What?
Telephone you.
I was going to say elevator music, but
it's not elevator music.
Yeah, I mean Stairway to Heaven, that's
Led Zeppelin.
Is it a sin?
Because that song is not really
Christian.
Oh, it's okay. So, you're saying by the
time these songs reach heaven, they're
sanctified and purged? So, it's okay?
Nice one, man. You got me. By the way,
who am I speaking to?
Uriel. Oh, you're one of the seventh
Archangels. Hey.
I wanted to know is Gabriel busy?
Because I have a friend here.
He wants him to read Ezekiel 33:8 for
him. Is he kind of busy?
Hold on. He says he's going to check for
me. Okay. Okay, can you play that music
again? All right, that's all right.
I wish I could put it on a speakerphone,
but one of the rules is you can't listen
in. It's only me. I got that direct
line.
And she's buying
stairway
to heaven.
>> [singing]
>> Hey, what's up, Uriel? What happened?
What?
Gabriel is out?
Where is he?
He's with Michael?
Where are they going?
Are you got to be kidding me? Hey, guys,
guess what? Gabriel and Michael
are actually in America. They're looking
for Hunter's
>> [clears throat]
>> computer.
All right. Hey, can you do me a favor?
When he gets back, can you have Gabriel
call me?
Appreciate you.
Shabbat shalom. And remember remember,
Uriel, she's buying
stairway from heaven.
Hey, you agree, too? My voice is
heavenly?
Then why the heck am I here? I should be
part of the choir. Baruch Hashem.
God, I'm sorry. Okay, see, I can only
use my privileges in very desperate
situations, so
I did it one more time. Here we go,
okay? Question, go ahead. What was it?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's
um
if the serpent didn't exist to tempt
um Eve
>> What happened? it what would happen will
Hold on. Yeah, that's basically it. Let
me call.
I got a direct line to heaven. Hold on.
>> [music]
>> Hold on. Sometimes, you know, it's busy
cuz a lot of people call heaven.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Hello.
Shalom aleichem.
As doch on, my tone.
Why you why you why?
David Joseph
I'm sorry. You want it in English,
right? Cuz I'm speaking in in tongues.
Uh Joseph
How are you doing, buddy?
You okay?
Yeah, of course you're okay. You're in
heaven, man. I'm the one that's not
okay. I got to pay taxes, IRS. Yeah,
pray for me, please, Joseph.
If you're wondering who Joseph this is
Joseph of Arimathea.
Yeah. So, Joseph, I want to ask you a
question. Um
If the serpent wasn't in the garden
would Adam and Eve have sinned?
Yeah, because this man is asking me a
hypothetical. I don't know how to answer
hypothetical.
I think he thinks maybe I have
omniscience that if there was an
alternate world
an alternate universe where there was no
serpent then I would know the outcome.
See you made this guy laugh so hard he's
laughing in my face. Joseph
Okay, all right. Can you stop laughing?
I can hear you Nuncio. It's not my
question. It's this guy's question.
Okay, I made an ass out of myself. All
right. Yabba dabba bye.
Sorry, sorry.
Yeah, I got I got I got I made this guy
laugh at me so hard they heard him on
the other side of heaven.
Go ahead. What was it?
So unless it's uh
emergency and necessary I try not to
call heaven too much. So it's okay. You
got your answer?
Yes, yes. You you give the answer, sir.
Good, sir. Thank you cuz they told me if
I keep abusing my privileges they're
going to cut off my line to heaven.
Yeah, man. No no worries. No worries.
I I won't I won't waste your time and
your calls. question. Remember
you know, this is my only lifeline. Get
it?
Lifeline?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, you're good now, brother? Yes,
yes, I am. I am.